veamos que dice aquí dice en la gráfica
siguiente para que valores de theta
coste no beteta es igual a 1 y para que
valores de teta coseno beteta es igual a
menos 1 como puedes ver la gráfica está
muy bonita lo hicieron muy bien para
nosotros aquí el eje horizontal es el
eje de la teta y el eje vertical es el
eje de leyes esta gráfica es que iguala
coseno de teta y de hecho tiene mucho
sentido con nuestra definición de
círculo unitario entonces voy a dibujar
aquí un círculo unitario y tal vez no
quede muy perfecto pero el chiste es
entender la idea de esto ahora cuando
teta es igual a cero estamos justamente
en este punto cierto ahora cuál es la
coordenada para x en este punto es uno
es uno y bueno como tú puedes ver cuando
teta es igual a cero en la gráfica
coseno de teta es igual a 1
ahora cuando te traes medios estamos en
este punto de acá arriba entonces
estamos justamente aquí en el círculo
unitario y cuál es la coordenada para x
la coordenada para x en este punto es
cero
así que es completamente consistente con
nuestra definición del círculo unitario
mientras nos movemos en la dirección
hacia enfrente nos estamos moviendo en
dirección contraria a las manecillas del
reloj en nuestro círculo unitario y
mientras nos movemos hacia atrás en el
círculo unitario nos movemos en la
dirección que va en la dirección que más
las manecillas del reloj la normal
alrededor de nuestro círculo unitario o
sea así entonces vamos a responder a la
pregunta dice bueno para qué valores
theta coseno de teta es igual a 1
veamos bueno podemos ver la gráfica que
que es igual a 1 cuando coste no hablo
lo voy a escribir acá con seno de teta
es igual a 1 en teta igual a 0 como
puedes ver aquí en teta igual a 0 y
después de mí bueno vamos a seguir la
gráfica y en teta igualados y también
con seno de teta es igual a 1 luego va a
seguir la gráfica sigue y sigue y tiene
mucho sentido
jose no detecta la coordenada x del
círculo unitario heras
y tuvimos que dar que viajar toda la
vuelta para llegar otra vez ese punto de
dos radiales pero luego daremos la
vuelta otra vez y otra vez para llegar a
dos radiales después cuatro pirra dianes
seis radiales y sigue y sigue creo aquí
te das cuenta del patrón que lleva esto
seguiremos obteniendo consciente está
igual a uno cada dos y radiant es cada
múltiplo de dos pi
entonces 2 viene donde n es un entero en
es un entero un entero y eso también
aplica valores negativos si vas en la
otra dirección no volvemos al punto de
partida hasta llegar a 2 pi nota que
estabas estábamos en cero luego estamos
en 1 otra vez cuando regresamos a menos
2 p luego menos 4 pi y luego menos 6
días y seguirá seguirá por los siglos de
los siglos
entonces esto aplica 100 es un entero si
n es negativo
de esta manera obtenemos todos los
valores negativos donde coseno de 30 es
igual a 1 y bueno ahora hay que pensar
cuando coseno de teatre es igual a menos
te da igual andy hay que ver la gráfica
podemos ver que cuando teta es igual a
pi ahí es menos 1 y la gráfica sigue y
sigue es cierto entonces voy a dibujar
sigue la gráfica infinitamente puedes
ver que también sería en 3 pib y en el
círculo unitario también lo puedes
visualizar muy bien coste 90 es igual a
menos 1 cuando estamos en este punto del
círculo unitario y eso sucede cuando
llegamos a pi radiales y no pasará otra
vez no vuelve a pasar hasta que
lleguemos a 3 y radiales entonces entre
sí radiales y otra vez hasta llegar a 5
y radiales y esto esto seguirá y seguirá
y seguirá indefinidamente entonces
también vale para direcciones negativas
si tomamos a 2 pidamos toda la vuelta de
hecho también aquí
- p - pi es una respuesta es una
respuesta - p de hecho lo puedes ver
aquí en la gráfica entonces puedes tú
pensar en esto como
n donde n es un entero 2 tiene más pi o
puedes también pensar en esto como 2 n 1
por pi y recuerda aquí en es un entero n
es un entero y en cada uno de estos
puntos para cada uno de estos te estás
costero de teta seguirá siendo menos 1
esto va a pasar una y otra y otra vez y
como puedes ver aquí también hay cierto
patrón que cumple como puedes ver la
gráfica va de un valle al otro valle y
toma una distancia de 2 para llegar de
un valle al otro valle entonces y aquí
acá es 2 pide aquí aquí también es 2 pi
y también tarda una distancia de dos
piden llegar de un monte al otro monte
de este a este es 2p y de este a éste
también es dos pitt bueno nos vemos
pronto fue todo por hoy